قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان حادثه تصادم الذي وقع بين
طائره المسيره الامريكيه ومقاتله روسيه
فوق البحر الاسود كان على الارجح غير
متعمد واشار برايس في مقابله مع محطه
تلفزيونيه الى ان التقييم الافضل حتى الان
يدل على ان الحادثه وقع بسبب انعدام
الكفاءه لدى احد الطيارين الروس حسب وصفه
اعتقد ان التقييم الافضل الان هو ان
الحادثه كان على الارجح غير مقصود وقد وقع
ربما بسبب عدم كفاءه احد الطيارين الروس
لكن ذلك غير مهم لان الحادثه وقع بالفعل
وكان ممكنا ان يتسبب في حادث اكبر بكثير
وسواء في هذه الحاله او في حالات اخرى لا
يمكن ان نرى هذا الامر يتكرر نظرا
لامكانيه التصعيد والمسيره الامريكيه كانت
فوق المياه الدوليه وعلى بعد اربعين ميلا
من شبه جزيره القرن والتي هي بالمناسبه في
اوكرانيا
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي انه اجرى اتصالا
مع نظير الروسي سيرجيو بشان حادثه المسيره
الامريكيه وقال اوستن ان قوه بلاده ستواصل
العمل في الاجواء المتاحه لها وفق القانون
الدولي وشدد اوستين على ضروره التواصل بين
واشنطن وموسكو ودع روسيا الى تشغيل
طائراتها العسكريه بطريقه امنه ومهنيه على
حد تعبيره مشيرا الى ان الطائرات الروسيه
قامت بعمل متهور وغير مسؤول فوق البحر
الاسود
اجريت اتصالا هاتفيا مع نظير الروسي
شويلغو كما قلت مرارا من المهم ان تكون
القوى العظمى نماذج للشفافيه والتواصل
الولايات المتحده ستواصل الطيران والعمل
حيثما يسمح القانون الدولي بذلك ويتعين
على روسيا تشغيل طائراتها العسكريه بطريقه
امنه ومهنيه
اما رئيسها الامريكيه المشتركه مارك ميلي
فقط قال ان اعتراض المقاتل الروسيه
للمسيره الامريكيه كان متعمدا دون ان يحسم
فيما اذا كانت تسعى الاسقاطها
اضافايا المسيره في البحر الاسود سيكون
صعبا عن هذه البقايا توجد في مستوى قد يصل
الى خمسه الاف قدم تحت المياه
لا نعرف النيات واخطط للحديث مع النظير
الروسي فهناك مكالمه مجدوله وسنرى ما اذا
كانت ستتم لا نعلم بعد ما اذا كان الاسقاط
متعمدا ام لا لكننا نعلم ان الاعتراض كان
متعمدا كما ان السلوك العدوانيه مقصود
وكان غير مهني وغير امن للغايه لدينا دليل
مصور على الاعتراض الذي كان عدوانيا
للغايه كما تم القاء الوقود على المسيره
ولست متاكدا من احتكاك الطائره بها من
الواضح اننا لا نسعى الى صراع مسلح مع
روسيا ويجب ان نحقق في هذا الحادث
قالت رساله الدفاع الروسيه ان وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجيو بحث هاتفيا حديثا مسيره
الامريكيه مع نظيره الامريكي بمبادره من
الجانب الامريكي واضافت الوزاره ان الشويك
اكد للوزير الامريكي الاحاديث الطائره
المسيره يعود الى عدم امتثال واشنطن
لمنطقه الطيران المقيده التي اعلنتها
موسكو واضافت الوزاره اكد لنظيره ان
اطلعات الجويه قباله سواحل القرن
استفزازيه وتخلق اجواء من التصعيد كما اكد
ان روسيا ستواصل رد بشكل مناسب على جميع
الاستفزازاتي بالقرب من حدودها
انتقد وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
بتجاهل الولايات المتحده المستفز لاغلاق
روسيا مناطق من البحر الاسود قريبه من
اوكرانيا امام كل انواع الطائرات فقال
لافروف في تعقيب على سقوط المسيره
الامريكيه ان واشنطن تواصل استفزازتها ان
هذه الاستفزازات محفوفه بمخاطر مواجهه
مباشره بين قوتين نوويتين عالميتين
يتجاهلون تماما واقع انه بعد بدء العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه اعلن جيشنا مناطق متاخمه
للساحل في البحر الاسود مناطق ذات وضع
محدود لاستخدامها من قبل اي طائره مثل هذا
التجاهل المستفز لهذه الحقيقه الموضوعيه
يوحي ان الجانب الامريكي يحاول باستمرار
البحث عن نوع من الاستفزاز لتصعيد
المواجهه هذا سيء لانهم اعلنوا باستمرار
انهم قوه مسؤوله لكن الاقوال لا تتطابق مع
الافعال اي حوادث تثير صداما بين قوتين
نوويتين عظمين هما الاكبر في العالم دائما
ما تنطوي على مخاطر جسيمه لا يمكنهم الا
ان يفهموا هذا